[Música]
a
más de 56 millones de venezolanos han
emigrado en los últimos años
especialmente a países como ecuador perú
y colombia este último es el mayor
receptor con 18 millones de inmigrantes
del vecino país el año pasado miles de
ellos enfrentaron situaciones de extrema
pobreza e incluso miseria cuando las
restricciones por la pandemia les
impidieron trabajar y a falta de
políticas públicas que los acogieran
frente a ello el gobierno colombiano
creó el estatuto de protección temporal
para migrantes que regulará su situación
por 10 años pero pese a este avance
preocupa el aumento de la xenofobia en
colombia cada vez son más recurrentes
los mensajes en las redes en los que se
asocia a los venezolanos con actos
delictivos según denuncia el barómetro
de la xenofobia esta entidad está alerta
de un aumento de mensajes
discriminatorios especialmente tras unas
controversiales declaraciones de la
alcaldesa de bogotá claudia lópez quien
meses atrás llegó a asociar a estos
ciudadanos
asesinatos
[Música]
el número de menores migrantes no
acompañados y de familias que ingresaron
a eeuu en el pasado mes ha disminuido
con respecto a meses anteriores pero aún
así las cifras siguen siendo
preocupantes porque todavía rozan esos
máximos históricos de los últimos 20
años para que se hagan una idea en el
pasado mes más de 14.100 menores no
acompañados ingresaron en el país una
cifra por debajo del mes anterior que
fueron más de 17.000 o del mes de marzo
que fue ese máximo histórico de 18.000
menores en la administración de joe
biden ha mantenido algunas de las reglas
implantadas por donald trump en
inmigración pero también ha revocado
muchas otras que según sus detractores
se están siendo las causantes de esta
crisis que se está viviendo en la
frontera sur
de hecho los gobernadores de los estados
sureños de texas y arizona han pedido a
la administración de joe biden que les
ayude a contener la crisis y quien ha
salido inmediatamente al rescate ha sido
precisamente el gobernador
de santis que ha dicho que enviará a sus
agentes para frenar esta crisis que hay
en la frontera sur ante la incapacidad
ha dicho de la administración de bryde
en de buscar una solución al problema
[Música]
dos semanas sin hielo
han desaparecido en el océano atlántico
tratando de alcanzar las islas canarias
ha sido la denuncia la organización de
defensa de derechos humanos caminando
fronteras su monitoreo sitúa en casi
4.000 a las víctimas de la frontera
occidental euro africana en los últimos
tres años y tras las desapariciones de
estas personas migrantes ninguna
institución estatal se encarga de su
búsqueda e identificación por lo que no
existen registros oficiales a los que
puedan agarrarse de sus familias de
hecho hace unas semanas más de 8000
personas procedentes de marruecos
lograron cruzar al enclave española de
ceuta entre ellas muchos menores de edad
y refugiados que fueron expulsados
directamente al país vecino y muchas
familias han reportado la desaparición
de sus seres queridos y cabe recordar en
este contexto que españa y marruecos ya
atraviesan su mayor crisis diplomática
en 20 años y utilizan la migración para
presionarse en el caso de españa en la
unión europea pagar millonarias
cantidades a marruecos a para que
bloquee los flujos migratorios y ahora a
marruecos busca que reconozcan su
soberanía sobre el sáhara occidental'
[Música]